jo leute herzlich zu diesem video wir
letzte woche schon auf die heftigsten
film tricks reagiert und diese woche
wieder ein in die welt der film und
zieht die icons und reagieren diesmal
auf das heftigste cgi schreck strich
visual effects los geht's hier wird und
da sind die dinosaurier klar den sind
nicht echt aber die sehen auch in
montreal aus was als auf die widersacher
von echten menschen mehr oder weniger
gespielt wurden sie dann einfach überall
wurde heftig life of pi natürlich auch
nicht wirklich mit einem echten tiger
gefilmt auf einer meiner lieblingsfilme
hat auch unter gallery the facts gab und
dieser tiger alter der sieht komplett
aus und der so richtig geil aber jetzt
auch komplett sicher
und hier sieht man wie das einfach von
außen aussieht und die hat einfach hier
ein bluescreen gehabt und das sind ja
mal holt krass also das einzige was
echtes ist quasi er und dieses schiff
logischerweise und weil diese chef zum
marketing haben ja auch unter dem schiff
sind traurig anlagen liegt weil sie das
schiff hin und her wandern lassen damit
es eben komplett ausgestiegen da haben
ja auch so genannte ton angeben hier
sind wir denn in grün hier diesen sieger
der natürlich komplett nicht echt ist
aber wohl eines der schwierigsten sachen
digitale 3d bereich ist es keine
computeranimierten sachen zusammen und
menschen interagieren zu lassen das halt
wenn jetzt mal spritzige auf den seinen
shows drauflegt natürlich müssen auch
zwei die haare des tigers irgendwie dann
eingedeckt werden wenn er so auf den fuß
drauf kommt und der schatten ist nämlich
auch ultra schwer denn um den schatten
in 3d richtig sie muss man nämlich nicht
nur den tiger 3d animieren sondern auch
ein 3d modell von dem schoß von dem
schauspieler zum beispiel machen damit
war der computer berechnen kann die der
schaden von dem tiger nämlich auf den
schoß drauf gehen würde dann kann man
diesen schatten falls sie einfach über
das fdp-mitglied auflegen und dann sieht
das so aus als würde dass da wirklich
drauf kommen wird die handels aber mit
seiner wenigen blauen kuppel gefilmt was
das sind ja überhaupt sogar
ok captain america ist ein guter film
wir sehen natürlich den arena und
eigentlich habe ich mir heute auch ein
anderes video angekündigt aber es ist so
aufwendig deswegen kommt als nächste
woche aber könnte man ein bisschen was
sehen
[Musik]
sie natürlich nicht ganz so gut aus wie
hier im film wo 10.000 vision rezept
götter dran arbeiten aber ist die ultra
viel arbeit und ich freue mich schon
richtig auf das fertige video kommt
nächsten freitag auf einem kanal also
abonniert mich gerne und aktiviert auch
die glocke dann werdet ihr direkt
erinnert wenn es nächsten freitag und
das ist auch total geil einfach alles
grün sekunden lagen aber so ein paar
steine herum aber natürlich gar nichts
echt also hier ist wirklich überhaupt
nichts echt und diese riesen green
screens die wiederum haben ne okay war
denn hier jetzt von batman oder superman
wir möchten nicht dass es so krass
auch der batman fast so sieht also nein
das kann jetzt endlich mal bei wadan
bleiben also ultra heftig böse aus und
der schauspieler es ein stuntman der
sich gerade so wird zum paar trekkingrad
and drop mein gott das ist ja jetzt
kommen wir zur arbeit haben film den ich
auch richtig geil finde da kommt im
übrigen zweite teil glaube ich 2021 oder
so hoffe ich dann endlich mal irgendwann
und bruder das war ja mal ein cgi
meisterwerk der film kam vor zehn jahren
alt und da ist ja auch logisch dass
nichts behauptet die schauspieler so
fahren die welt hier komplett 3d
animiert hier alle mit motion capturing
anzügen auch mit facial capturing dass
die gesichtsbewegungen nach animiert
werden haben die natürliche punkte auf
den gesichtern und dann erkennt der
computer wie sich diese punkte bewegung
und überträgt sein quasi diese bewegung
auf dem 3d modell und dann kann man
quasi das 3d modell animieren ohne dass
man selber animiert muss sind auf jeden
fall viel realistischer aus als wenn du
die man selber machen würde wie jetzt
hier die avenches auch natürlich ein
urteil hatte das projekt
apropos avengers ich habe in avengers
endgame eine kamera reingeschmuggelt ich
habe dazu auch ein video gemacht wird
hier und in den videos habe ich auch wie
ich diesen schrott hier gerade mit thors
hammer gemacht habt also dass man hier
aus wenn ihr das sehen möchte also das
ist heftig weil hier sitzt die st galler
tor ins aus
mit diesen ganzen track i marken und
hierbei mit hocker auch alles
komplizierter alle das ist dass es da so
heftig das so zu sehen
ist das echt krass ja auch herr der
ringe und reibt sich was mich angeht die
filme sind auch schon mir wohl für alt
hobbit alter hobbys richtig nah ist hier
diese hohe töne war einfach alles
klinsmann ist auch dieser bogen ist
einfach so ein green screen leiter und
man hat einfach eine hobbit die ganzen
hobbits sind einfach komplett 3d
animiert und das einzige wasser drin
release ist dieser skandal
das ist eine heftige schauspielerische
leistung was der da einfach betreibt
hier auch ihren mann und diese szene
alter mann kennt sie wo die gute körper
nach hinten verlegt und weiß einfach
nicht echt sind einfach nur alles hier
so und bilder dreidimensional im raum
angeordnet sind die dann quasi dieses
dieses dieses haus bilden und eine vorne
so verschiedene partikel angefügt und
rauch und verschiedene bruchstücke hier
oder das ist beeindruckend
die auch argumente und natürlich ist
hier gar nichts außer dieses mal wieder
und das ist die szene die ultra geiles
wurde das ganz einfach auf dem rücken
von diesem gut drauf ist richtig so
richtig lustig und die szene ist auch
richtig geil aus alice im wunderland
wollen wir diese diese leute mit seinem
tanz ja wie einfach aussehen so
glühbirnen mit so stellten als ob witzig
das ist das was als ob alles genau way
away warte warte warte bei stressig wald
dieser dinosaurier das wird einfach
gespielt von der menschen und auch der
menschen wie dumm sie das programm sieht
es aus
im hintergrund diese ganzen typen da die
diesen kindern heißt die firma die auf
jeden fall al arisch brauch ich ja auch
alles im green screen 1911 parierte
kelvin ist auch so heftig mit diesen
tentakeln bruder dieser tage von
dissidenten wichtig sind so ultra geil
wir sind erstens mal beeindruckend aus
die reflektion auf und realistisch und
diese ganzen tag hier singt weil sie so
3d animierte dass die nicht einfach
herunter hängen sie schnüre sondern dass
die auch noch so dass die auch
miteinander interagieren und war sowieso
ein muskel strang so richtig fest sind
und deswegen nicht herunter hängen wieso
haare sondern wirklich muskeln haben und
sich teilweise auch noch natürlich
bewegen und das vst zucker als hier auch
wolf of wall street wo ich gar nicht
damit gerechnet habe dass da irgendwas
tut weil ganz ehrlich damit hast du halt
überhaupt nicht bei dem film hat der
film hat jetzt überhaupt 00 sa 14 krass
sind aber dass auch ultra high
performance aller da waren die cgi
effekte heftig wurde das ist so geil
wird diese motion capturing mein gott
dieses aliens also richtig geil aus ohne
witz das war dass dieser film egal was
jetzt auch halter der auch jetzt die
story kann oder was weiß ich die neuen
stars teilhaben so geile cinematics und
kamera fallen und szenerien die komplett
irgendwie aus dem boden gestampft wurden
irgendjemand diesen hintergrund immerhin
gezeichnet hat und an die visual effects
leute das quasi nachgestellt haben
ultras ge sherlock holmes das sieht man
auch dass er nächstes und erzielen wir
diese ganzen einzelnen ebenen daran
gesetzt werden und zack zack zack zack
die ganzen häuser der ganzen schichten
und einfach nichts ist echt und wie viel
arbeit das ist alter das alles zu
animieren und sich das alles zu
überlegen und das alles in 3d zu machen
und wird echte filmmaterial kreises für
mich nicht liebe das wenn man dich liebe
das wirklich wenn man so vorher nachher
sieht wie das davor aussieht und wie
diese ganzen einzelne schichten von
visual effects zauberei also rein
gestapelt werden ultra ultra
faszinierend hier der marsianer was wohl
war dies komplett 3d animiert
ökologisches dazu komplett trainieren
und dann einfach ins gesicht drauf
gesetzt das waren auf jeden fall polizei
das inspiriert kompletter so dass sie
wirklich war absolut geil
auch wenn man natürlich für solche sagen
ein ganzes team braucht 100000 der leute
da an einem strang ziehen und wird auch
ihr bock habt so etwas kreatives zu
machen und auf dem pfad der digitalen
kunst beginn wollte kann ich euch
empfehlen mit dem schneiden von videos
anzufangen und dann darauf aufzubauen
und visual effects und bildverarbeitung
alles möglich aber ich finde macht sinn
mit dem schneiden anzufangen wenn ihr
noch nicht schneiden können dann könnt
euch mal ein stück größer erklärt in
zwei stunden detailliert wie man
schneidet das ist für komplette anfänger
geeignet aber auch etwas
fortgeschrittenere leute die werden ja
immer noch was lernen man wird halt das
ganze natürlich nicht monatlich sondern
nur einmal und kann sich dann zu oft
angucken wie man möchte also checkt es
aus diesen kurs haben sie schon über 135
leute gekauft ist es so heftig alter das
ist weggezogen und wir schreiben jeden
tag leute dass sie den kursen und dass
er den weiterhilft und selbst leute die
gerade irgendwie auch der filmschule
scheinbar sind und denen der tod entging
nichts beibringen selbst solche leute
schreiben mir das in meinen kurs roth
fall weiterhilft und das ist einfach nur
oder dass das ist einfach nur richtig
ich kann sie beschreiben leute wenn euch
das video gefallen hat und lasse mir
keinen daumen nach oben da die original
klubs in der video beschreibung und wenn
er mich auf dieser reise begleiten
möchte und auch das video nächster woche
gesehen wollte weil das ultra heftig
dann abonniert mich und dann sehen wir
zunächst mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]